environ 200 pêcheurs en colère se sont
réunis ce matin devant les bureaux de
l'union des pêcheurs des maritimes à
shediac c'est le tiers de toute la
flottille de pêche du détroit de
northumberland
prix avoisinant les 5 $ la livre de
homard il estime qu il leur coûtera plus
cher d'aller pêcher que de rester à quai
ces ballons table tout ça pour ça dure
jusqu'au rancoeurs nées après puis à ce
port leucate et nice acceptable moi
c'est qu'on apprécie bias je le mets
rage
les faibles prix de cette saison
combinée à la hausse du coût de la vie
et des taux d'intérêt plus élevés mettre
sérieusement en danger la survie de
certaines entreprises de pêche comme
l'expliquent le capitaine georges
arsenault 22 ans qui a récemment acheté
un bateau
ça fils mohamed allal ouvrage puis sacko
de l'argent vous travaillez c'est pas
bien en bout sur l'action des pêcheurs
se veut une tentative de forcer la main
des acheteurs les usines de
transformation pour hausser les prix une
tentative qui risquent de tomber à plat
ce genre d'action lors change en rien
les conditions de marché qu'on observe
depuis quatre mois
ni les perspectives
de marché dans les mois qui viennent
donc
on l'a déjà dit je comprends la
frustration
on comprend la déception qui est l'or
qui est réel les usines de
transformation qui emploie elle même des
milliers de travailleurs dans le sud est
du nouveau brunswick sont aux prises
avec des inventaires important de
produits invendus en raison du
ralentissement des marchés
l'arrêt de la pêche ne vont en rien aidé
cette situation et conditions de marché
sont tellement
compliquées dans le moment
comment mon inquiétude c'est que
[Musique]
si les usines n'ont pas un
approvisionnement stable prévisible de
produits il y en a peut-être qui vont
choisir si ça dure
de fermer les bancs
si vous êtes au courant il ya des
confirmé aujourd'hui à 11 heures petite
consolation les prix ont légèrement
augmenté aujourd'hui ce qui n'est par
ailleurs toujours pas suffisant pour les
pêcheurs seront
au
milieu les eaux mardi font dans une
saison les revenus de toute une année et
plus la saison avance - le homard sera
abondant chaque jour est donc compté pas
savoir combien de temps les pêcheurs
resteront à quai et cynique alassane bac
radio-canada à shediac